SPEAKER 1: Hey, everybody.
Welcome to the Flutter
channel here on YouTube.
Flutter is a portable
UI toolkit built
by Google and the
open source community,
and we've got tons
of great videos
to show you how to use it.
SPEAKER 2: Like
"Widget of the Week,"
a series of short
animated videos
introducing different
Flutter widgets.
SPEAKER 3: And
"Flutter in Focus,"
a series of deep dives into
important topics like--
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 3: And "Flutter in
Focus," a series of deep dives
into important
topics like widget
composition and
asynchronous coding.
SPEAKER 4: And
"The Boring Show,"
where we code apps, answer
questions, and have no fun
whatsoever.
SPEAKER 5: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
SPEAKER 1: Whoa!
SPEAKER 6: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
We've got live events
and stories about real
developers building with
Flutter.
SPEAKER 7: And visits
from the engineering team.
SPEAKER 8: With developers from
places all over the world--
SPEAKER 9: From China.
SPEAKER 10: From India.
SPEAKER 11: From Peru.
SPEAKER 12: From Poland.
SPEAKER 13: And Dash, too.
SPEAKER 1: So if this sounds
like the kind of thing
you're looking for, head
over to the Flutter channel,
where you can find all of
our videos in one place.
We have a lot to show you.
SPEAKER 13: Got it?
SPEAKER 1: All right.
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER 7: Hey, if you
thought that was cool,
you should check out
this or check out that.
But don't forget to subscribe
to the Flutter YouTube channel.